This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vidantam. This episode is a radio replay, a pairing of two previously-aired podcast episodes that we've married together to play on our radio show. What you're about to listen to is a combo of the episodes, pedestals and guillotines, and the perils of power. We're calling it the power hour. Power dynamics shape everything in our society, from high school...
这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本期节目是广播重播，我们将两期之前播出的播客节目合二为一，在我们的广播节目中播出。你即将听到的是两期节目的结合，即“基座与断头台”以及“权力的危险”。我们将其称为“权力时刻”。权力动力学塑造了我们社会中的一切，从高中……
You're wearing sweatpants. So, so that's against the rules, and you can't sit with us. ...to the highest court of the land. We'll hear argument first this morning in case 10, 5,400... ...topia versus... What are the qualities that give people power? And what happens to us when we have it? We answer those questions and more on today's show.
你穿着运动裤。所以，这违反了规则，你不能和我们坐在一起。……到国家最高法院。今天上午我们首先听取第10、5400号案件的辩论……托比亚诉……究竟是什么特质赋予了人们权力？当我们拥有权力时，我们自身又会发生什么变化？在今天的节目中，我们将回答这些以及更多问题。
Alright, let's get to it. Welcome to Los Angeles, the celebrity capital of the world. It's a city that conjures palm-line boulevards, crawling mansions, luxury cars. At the center of all the glitz, Hollywood. Movie stars aren't the only ones here. Star gazers are drawn here too, like paperclips to a magnet. And point your attention to the left, because we are seeing Beverly Hills for the first time
好了，言归正传。欢迎来到洛杉矶，世界名流之都。这是一座让人联想到棕榈树成荫的大道、庞大的豪宅、豪华轿车的城市。而在所有浮华的中心，则是好莱坞。在这里，电影明星可不是唯一的主角。追星族也被吸引到这里，就像回形针遇到磁铁一样。请把注意力转向左边，因为我们正在第一次看到比弗利山庄
on the left hand side. Wow, some big houses down there, right? With the Mewzac blaring, a handful of people on a celebrity tour pure out there van, hoping to glimpse the homes of LA's rich and famous. The guide points out Gwen Stefani's house, and a clump of bushes behind which she claims is Quentin Tarantino's home.
在左手边。哇，下面有一些大房子，对吧？伴随着轻音乐的轰鸣，几个人在一辆观光车里进行名人故居之旅，希望能瞥见洛杉矶富豪名流的家。导游指出了格温·斯特凡尼的房子，以及她声称昆汀·塔伦蒂诺家所在的一丛灌木。
She pulls up Nyakati Perry's compound. Do I have any Katy Perry fans, Abord? Fine, it works. Okay, well here's her house. Look up to your left, and you'll see the awning, the red awning. You can't really see it's red there, but we are right beneath her house.
她把车开到了凯蒂·佩里的宅邸前。车上有凯蒂·佩里的粉丝吗？好吧，算啦，行得通。好吧，这就是她的房子。抬头看左边，你会看到遮阳篷，红色的遮阳篷。你在那里可能看不清它是红色的，但我们就位于她房子正下方。
She actually owns the entire corner here and look at her view. It's amazing, isn't it? One of the tour's most popular sites is the home of Kim Kardashian, while sort of. Kanye and Kim needed a house to have their friends over and on the left hand side, this is the house they use. rented for 12,000 a month, there's somebody right behind it, so I can't stop. I'm sorry about that.
她实际上拥有这里的整个拐角，看看她的视野。太棒了，不是吗？这次旅行中最受欢迎的景点之一是金·卡戴珊的家，勉强算是吧。坎耶和金需要一处房子来招待朋友，在左手边，这就是他们使用的房子。以每月1.2万美元的价格租下，后面正有人，所以我不能停车。对此我很抱歉。
But that is the house right there. Has its own little swimming pool. Boy, they had some big parties too. Tours like this are big business. Andrew Imordino helps manage the tour company called Star Trek. He says, not just Americans, but people from all over the world sign up for these tours. And they kind of want to just get that little feel, that little taste of what it's like to, you know,
但那栋房子就在那里。它有自己的小游泳池。天哪，他们也办过一些盛大的派对。这样的旅行是一门大生意。安德鲁·伊莫迪诺帮助管理着一家名为“星际迷航”的旅游公司。他说，不仅是美国人，来自世界各地的人都会报名参加这些旅行。他们只是想获得那种感觉，那种体验，去了解，你知道的，
see the celebrity's homes and do all the crazy stuff that you see in the magazines and the television. But it's more than just wanting a taste of celebrity culture. The glitz and glamour, the swimming pools, the manicured grounds, the storied homes, humans, hunger for a chance to pure into and fantasize about lives of luxury and extravagance. This extends to our political leaders too. We adore the pomp of state dinners and inaugural balls. We dream of what it must be like when presidents make life and death decisions for a nation. No matter how long it may take us, to overcome this premeditated invasion,
去看名人的家，做你在杂志和电视上看到的那些疯狂的事情。但这不仅仅是想要体验名人文化。浮华与魅力、游泳池、修剪整齐的庭院、传奇般的住宅，人类内心渴望有机会一窥并幻想奢华与挥霍的生活。这也延伸到了我们的政治领袖身上。我们崇拜国宴和就职舞会的排场。我们梦想着总统为国家做出生死决定的感觉会是怎样。无论需要我们花多长时间，来克服这场蓄意的侵略，
the American people in their righteous might will win through to absolute victory. We fantasize about what it must mean to be fabulously rich and powerful. Words can't describe how beautiful it was. Everything you saw was breathtaking. And we got to meet his girlfriend, Melania, who is amazing as well. Hi, hi, I'm Melania. Nice to meet you. Colled adulation, adoration, idolization.
美国人民将凭其正义的力量走向绝对的胜利。我们幻想成为富可敌国、大权在握的人会是什么样。言语无法形容它是多么美丽。你看到的一切都令人叹为观止。我们还见到了他的女朋友梅拉尼娅，她也一样令人惊叹。嗨，嗨，我是梅拉尼娅。很高兴见到你。虚荣的奉承、崇拜、偶像化。
Humans are prone to suck up to the rich and powerful. But this turns out to be only one side of our psychology. On the other side it's something entirely different. Many of us hate the rich because they're rich. We want to see the powerful topple from their pedestals. We enjoy seeing the glamorous fall and fail. The lure of celebrity tours is rivaled only by the popularity of tabloid magazines, detailing the rehab trips and broken marriages of those same celebrities. Today on the show, we'll explore our ambivalence towards power, and what happens to us when we get power ourselves. And it really lends credence to Lord Acton's old observation that I think stands the test of time,
人类倾向于拍有钱有势之人的马屁。但这只是我们心理学的一个方面。另一方面则完全不同。我们中的许多人痛恨富人，只因为他们富有。我们希望看到掌权者从权力的宝座上跌落。我们喜欢看到光鲜亮丽的人陨落和失败。名人故居之旅的诱惑力，只有那些详尽报道这些名人戒毒之旅和破碎婚姻的八卦杂志的受欢迎程度才能与之媲美。今天在节目中，我们将探讨我们对权力的矛盾心理，以及当我们自己获得权力时会发生什么。这确实证明了阿克顿勋爵的那句老话，我认为经受住了时间的考验，
which is power corrupts and absolute power corrupts absolutely. The parallels of power this week on Hidden Brain. On a pre-drawn morning, a high-stalker in Paris. Breaking news this morning, Kim Kardashian robbed at gunpoint in Paris late last night by five men dressed as police officers. The robbers made off not only with Kim case 20-carat, emerald-cut diamond engagement ring, but other jewels and cash totaling more than $10 million. The news media was sympathetic to Kim's ordeal. A source close to Kim tells ET the mother of two is still very, very shaken up.
那就是权力导致腐败，绝对权力绝对腐败。本周《隐藏的大脑》将探讨权力的双面性。在一个预定好的早晨，巴黎的一名高级跟踪狂。今天早上的突发新闻，金·卡戴珊昨晚深夜在巴黎被五名身穿警服的男子持枪抢劫。劫匪不仅抢走了金那枚价值2000万克拉、祖母绿切割的钻石订婚戒指，还抢走了其他珠宝和现金，总计超过1000万美元。新闻媒体对金的遭遇表示同情。接近金的消息人士告诉《今夜娱乐》，这位两个孩子的母亲仍然非常、非常震惊。
Quote, she thought she was going to die. They put a gun to her head while they were searching the apartment. She was crying begging them for her life. The sympathy didn't last long, especially on social media. Andrea McDonald is a communications professor who is interested in celebrity culture. There's a tweet here that says, quote, Kim Kardashian was held at gunpoint in a Paris hotel. Man will be charged with not pulling the trigger and saving humanity from mediocrity.
她说，她以为自己死定了。当他们在搜查公寓时，他们把枪顶在她的头上。她一直在哭泣，乞求他们饶她一命。这种同情并没有持续多久，尤其是在社交媒体上。安德里亚·麦克唐纳是一位对名人文化感兴趣的传播学教授。这里有一条推文写道，“金·卡戴珊在巴黎的一家酒店遭到持枪抢劫。这个男人将被指控没有扣动扳机，从而拯救人类免于平庸。”
Or this post. After years of desperation, Kim Kardashian finally has a reason to be in the news today. There were other snarky comments. Maybe Kim faked the robbery as a publicity stunt. Maybe she faked it so she could disappear for more plastic surgery. Where was the love, the outpouring of concern from Kim's millions of fans? Why, after a brutal robbery, did people turn on her? Andrea has a theory. Kim Kardashian is someone who has made her whole living out of being famous and
或者这条动态。经过多年的绝望，金·卡戴珊今天终于有了一个上新闻的理由。还有其他尖酸刻薄的评论。也许金是自导自演了这场抢劫来作为一场公关噱头。也许她是假装抢劫，好让自己消失去进行更多的整容手术。爱在哪里？金的数百万粉丝排山倒海般的关心在哪里？为什么在经历了一场残酷的抢劫后，人们却反过来攻击她？安德里亚有一个理论。金·卡戴珊是一个完全靠出名来维持生计的人，
employing her fame to make money and really flaunting her success and wealth in various ways and so when that wealth is quite literally attacked in a very confrontational and personal way our in a very confrontational and personal way, our potential empathy for her, even if we are fans of hers, may be lacking there because of our own potential envy or distaste for some of her personal presentation of wealth. In other words, as much as many of us like seeing the rich and luxurious world of Kim, we don't like the idea that she's rubbing it in our faces, and so we don't mind when she's
并且利用她的名气来赚钱，并通过各种方式大肆炫耀她的成功和财富，因此，当这种财富在一次非常具有对抗性和个人化的方式中被字面意义上地攻击时，我们对她的潜在同情，即使我们是她的粉丝，也可能会因为我们自己潜在的嫉妒或对她某些个人财富展示的厌恶而有所缺失。换句话说，尽管我们中的许多人喜欢看金那富裕奢华的世界，但我们不喜欢她把这一切拍在我们脸上的想法，所以当她遭遇挫折时，我们并不介意。
taken down a few notches. We do the same with our political leaders. We adore the pomp and circumstance associated with high office, but we pounce at the slightest gaff. Vice President Dan Quale was all but drawn and quartered when he urged a little boy to add an e to the spelling of the word potato. And Texas Governor Rick Perry suffered a moment of forgetfulness during a presidential debate. The third agency of government I would do away with the education, the commerce, and let's see, I can't.
我们对我们的政治领袖也是如此。我们崇拜高位带来的浮华与礼仪，但我们会在哪怕微小的失误时猛烈抨击。副总统丹·奎尔敦促一个小男孩在“potato”这个词的拼写后面加上一个字母e时，几乎遭到了五马分尸般的批判。而德克萨斯州州长里克·佩里在总统辩论中经历了一刻的健忘。我将废除的第三个政府机构是教育部、商业部，让我想想，我想不起来了。
That was the end of Rick Perry's role in the National Spotlight. At least until President Donald Trump chose him to leave the department he couldn't remember. Energy. Governor Howard Deans 2004 campaign for president came to a crashing halt when he ended a televised speech with slightly too much enthusiasm. We're going to South Carolina and Oklahoma and Arizona
那是里克·佩里在国家聚光灯下角色的终结。至少直到唐纳德·特朗普总统选择他去领导那个他记不住的部门。能源部。2004年霍华德·迪恩州长的总统竞选在电视演讲结束时由于表现出稍许过度的热情而戛然而止。我们要去南卡罗来纳州、俄克拉荷马州、亚利桑那州
and North Dakota and New Mexico. We're going to California and Texas and New York. We're going to South Dakota and Oregon and Washington and Michigan. And then we're going to South Dakota, and Oregon, and Washington, and Michigan, and then we're going to Washington, and he's seen to take back the White House! You get the point. We can adore our leaders one moment and skewer them the next. Not long ago, I was watching all the way, a wonderful movie about Lyndon B. Johnson, starring
北达科他州和新墨西哥州。我们要去加利福尼亚州、得克萨斯州和纽约州。我们要去南达科他州、俄勒冈州、华盛顿州和密歇根州。然后我们要去南达科他州、俄勒冈州、华盛顿州和密歇根州，然后我们要去华盛顿，他看起来要夺回白宫了！你明白我的意思了。我们可以上一秒崇拜我们的领袖，下一秒就尖刻地批评他们。不久前，我一直在观看《全方位的爱》，这是一部关于林登·B·约翰逊的精彩电影，由演员布莱恩·克兰斯顿主演。
actor Brian Cranston. There's one scene that stayed with me. It sums up the contradictory feelings humans have toward people in power. LBJ has just been elected president. He walks through an enduring crowd, and he says this to himself. Right now we're going party like there's no tomorrow, because there's no feeling in the world happens good as winning. But the sun will come up, and the knives will come out. And all these smiling faces will be watching me. Wait, one first moment of weakness, and then they will gut me like a deer.
有一个场景留在了我的记忆中。它总结了人类对权力人物的矛盾情感。LBJ刚刚当选总统。他穿过拥挤的人群，对自己说了这样一番话。现在我们要像没有明天一样狂欢，因为世上没有比获胜更好的感觉了。但太阳会升起，匕首也会出鞘。所有这些笑脸都会注视着我。等着吧，只要露出一丝软弱，他们就会像开膛破肚一只鹿一样把我掏空。
It's not a bad analogy, given that so much of our psychology was formed in the ancient past, when humans lived in small, nomadic tribes of hunter-gatherers. To understand the contradictory relationship that humans have with power, we need to go back in time, way back, to prehistory, to our evolutionary past. One way to do this is to observe the behavior of a close relative, the chimpanzee. As a young woman, the evolutionary anthropologist Anne PC walked deep into the Tanzanian forest. She was there as a student assistant to the primatologist Jane Goodall. Anne's job was to observe and record chimpanzee behavior in the wild.
这并不是一个坏的比喻，鉴于我们的心理很大一部分是在远古时期形成的，当时人类生活在小型、游牧的狩猎采集部落中。要理解人类与权力的这种矛盾关系，我们需要回到过去，追溯到史前时期，回到我们的进化过去。方法之一就是观察近亲黑猩猩的行为。作为一个年轻女性，演化人类学家安·佩克深入坦桑尼亚的森林。她当时是以灵长类动物学家简·古道尔的学生助手的身份去的。安的工作是观察并记录野生黑猩猩的行为。
Sometimes she'd watch the chimps at a feeding station loaded with bananas. Other times, she'd trail them. And following them around was pretty tough because it, as I said, a rugged place and so you're going up and down, you're crawling through vines, the paths, if there are paths that the chimps walk on are small and you have to often have to scramble through the vegetation. And if they didn't want to be followed, they could very easily lose you. Over time, and began to understand how the chimps engaged with each other.
有时她会在堆满香蕉的喂食站观察黑猩猩。有时，她会尾随它们。追踪它们相当困难，因为正如我所说，那是一个地形崎岖的地方，你得上上下下，得在藤蔓中爬行，黑猩猩走的小路（如果那也算路的话）很窄，你经常得在植被中艰难跋涉。如果它们不想被跟踪，很容易就能把你甩掉。随着时间推移，安开始理解黑猩猩是如何彼此交往的。
Chimps society is very male-dominated. The headhunt show is the alpha male. He's often the center of attention. The other males will groom him. He's probably groomed more by the other males are and the same the females pay particular attention to the alpha male as well partly because they get chased around by him more. So that there's certainly probably a benefit to individuals from having a good relationship with the alpha male from their own, you know, this point of view of safety and maybe support that they may gain from him. Often the younger males appear to idolise the alpha. Some of the
黑猩猩社会是一个高度由雄性主导的社会。首领是阿尔法雄性（首领雄性）。它通常是人们关注的中心。其他雄性会为它梳理毛发。它受到的来自其他雄性的梳理可能比其他雄性都要多，而且雌性也对阿尔法雄性给予了特别的关注，部分原因在于它们经常被阿尔法雄性追赶。因此，个体与阿尔法雄性保持良好的关系，从它们自身的安全以及可能从阿尔法雄性那里获得的支持等角度来看，肯定是有好处的。通常，年轻的雄性似乎对阿尔法雄性顶礼膜拜。我观察到的一些
males I watched, especially one in particular, just follow the alpha male around and you know, he, the alpha male would do a charging display and the alpha male around. And, you know, he, the alpha male would do a charging display, and the little male I was watching would sort of charge long behind him and kick the same buttress of the tree. But the relationship between the alpha and others in the group is more complicated than it might first seem. Christopher Bohm is a cultural anthropologist who also worked with Jane Goodall observing the chimps. Basically, if you look at the individual chimpanzees and how they behave around their superiors, it's rather ambivalent.
雄性，尤其是其中一个，总是跟着阿尔法雄性转，你知道的，阿尔法雄性会进行冲锋展示，而我观察到的小雄性也会跟着在它身后冲锋，并踢打同一棵树的树干。但阿尔法雄性与群里其他成员之间的关系比乍看起来要复杂得多。克里斯托弗·博姆是一位文化人类学家，他也曾与简·古道尔一起工作，观察黑猩猩。基本上，如果你观察单个黑猩猩以及它们在显贵周围的行为，就会发现这相当矛盾。
You can see the sembivalents each time the alpha male intimidates the other chimps. He basically goes crazy. He runs around erects all of his hair to look as big as possible. Uproots, trees, and throws them, picks up boulders, heaves them in the air, swings aggressively on finds, races around, and attacks any member of the group that doesn't show deference by going up a tree in a hurry. What Chris found interesting as he watched the chimps is what happened next. As they race up the trees, they are screaming, which is a fear of localization, which tells the alpha male I'm scared of you. So it's also a deference.
每当阿尔法雄性恐吓其他黑猩猩时，你都能看到这种矛盾心理。它基本上会发疯似地奔跑，竖起身上所有的毛发，让自己看起来尽可能庞大。连根拔起树木并将其扔掉，捡起巨石，将它们抛向空中，在藤蔓上气势汹汹地荡来荡去，四处狂奔，并攻击任何不通过赶紧爬上树来表现出顺从的群体成员。克里斯在观察黑猩猩时觉得有趣的是接下来发生的事情。当它们快速爬上树时，它们在尖叫，这是一种恐惧的发声，它告诉阿尔法雄性我怕你。所以这也是一种顺从。
But as they get up to the top of the tree, they then stop screaming and they give another call called the Waw Bark. And a Waw sounds something like this. Waw! But ever so much louder. And the Waw call is one of defiance and hostility. And so once they're up in the tree tops and they know he isn't going to take the trouble to come up and punish them, they all start whining at him. And this tells him and me that they don't like what he just did, because he's basically dominated and frightened them and forced them to run up a tree when they'd rather be on the ground feeding and so on.
但当它们爬到树顶时，它们就会停止尖叫，并发出另一种叫声，叫做“汪叫”（Waw Bark）。“汪”听起来有点像这样。汪！但是声音要大得多。“汪”叫是一种挑衅和敌意的呼喊。因此，一旦它们爬上了树顶，并且知道阿尔法雄性不会费心爬上来惩罚它们，它们就会开始对它发牢骚。这告诉它也告诉我，它们不喜欢它刚刚做的事，因为它基本上羞辱并吓唬了它们，强迫它们在它们更愿意在地面上觅食等时候逃上一棵树。
So in terms of political ambivalence toward the alpha male is pretty easy to identify once you know the species well. In other words, woven into the fabric of adulation and submission are strands of defiance and rebellion. Early humans seem to share the straight. Chris has studied nomadic hunter-gatherer tribes who have had almost no contact with the outside world and whose lives have changed little over thousands of years. What he found again was a
因此，就对阿尔法雄性的政治矛盾心理而言，一旦你对这个物种有了深入了解，就很容易识别出来。换句话说，交织在奉承和臣服织体中的，是挑衅和叛逆的丝线。早期人类似乎也有这种特征。克里斯研究过游牧的狩猎采集部落，他们几乎与世隔绝，生活几千年来几乎没有改变。他发现的同样是对
deep ambivalence about the powerful. Take for example one of the most powerful members of a hunter-gatherer tribe, the skilled hunter. And people love this guy, but the minute he tries to turn that meat into power, people love this guy, but the minute he tries to turn that meat into power, that is to keep the meat for himself and give it to his cronies and develop power that way, the group will treat him with extreme discuracy. They may criticize him. If it gets too bad, they may ostracize him. If it really gets too bad, and the guy is a real despot, and is trying to basically take other people's autonomy away, they'll kill him. The great hunter is admired and revered, but if he becomes too big for his boots, he's quickly taken down.
权势人物的深深矛盾心理。例如，狩猎采集部落中最有权势的成员之一，技术娴熟的猎人。人们很喜欢这家伙，但只要他试图将这些肉转化为权力，也就是说把肉留给自己并分给自己的亲信，并以此来发展权力，群体就会对这种行为极度反感。他们可能会批评他。如果情况变得更糟，他们可能会排挤他。如果真的变得很糟糕，这个家伙成了个真正的暴君，并试图剥夺其他人的自主权，他们就会杀了他。伟大的猎人受到钦佩和尊崇，但如果他过于狂妄自大，就会很快被拉下马。
In his book, Hierarchy and the forest, Chris concluded that early human society was marked by a remarkably egalitarianism. The roots of democracy he concluded weren't in the American Declaration of Independence or even in ancient Greece. They are woven into the DNA of human beings. Really, humans are somehow disposed to look up to those who are rich and powerful, and also to subject them to special scrutiny morally. And again, if you have a leader and you're watching out carefully that he doesn't overdevelop his power, that kind of scrutiny is very important. The fact that human beings have contradictory attitudes
克里斯在他的著作《等级与森林》中得出结论，早期人类社会的标志是显著的平等主义。他断言，民主的根基不在于《独立宣言》，甚至不在于古希腊。它们织入了人类的DNA中。实际上，人类一方面倾向于敬仰那些富有和权势的人，另一方面也会在道德上对他们进行特殊的审视。同样，如果你有一个领导者，并且你仔细防范他过度发展自己的权力，这种审视是非常重要的。人类对权力抱有矛盾态度这一事实
towards power is not lost on the rich and powerful. It's one reason Handlers work so hard to make leaders and celebrities look down to earth and humble. President Reagan was often shown in jeans and flannel shirt, cutting wood on his ranch or saddling up his horses. That used to ride and would just play down to him and I forget and girth up before I remember. The Kennedys went water skiing for fun
，有权有势的人心知肚明。这也是为什么幕后推手们如此努力地让领导者和名人们显得接地气、谦逊的原因之一。人们经常看到里根总统穿着牛仔裤和法兰绒衬衫，在牧场里砍柴或给马备鞍。我过去常常骑马，并且会把肚带系好，在我记忆中……肯尼迪家族去滑水是为了消遣
and remember to bring the media along. It's a family outing in Louis Bay, Hianna Sport for the Kennedys. The president, accompanied by his kind of a blessing father, his brothers, and a full complement of children, relaxes from the cares of Washington with a day on the water. Beloved leaders aren't the only ones who've learned this trick.
并且记得带上媒体。这是肯尼迪家族在路易斯湾、海恩斯港的一次家庭远足。总统在慈父般的父亲、兄弟们以及一大群孩子的陪伴下，在水上度过了一天，放松了华盛顿的烦恼。受人爱戴的领导者并不是唯一学会这一招的人。
In 2011, Vogue ran a puff piece about Asma Alassad and her husband Bashar. She was the rose in the desert. Together, they were the beautiful, down-to-earth couple, deeply committed to empowering citizens in Syrian civil society. Two years later, the Assad regime used chemical weapons on its own people. Or consider this.
2011年，《Vogue》杂志刊登了一篇关于阿斯玛·阿萨德和她的丈夫巴沙尔的吹捧文章。她是沙漠中的玫瑰。他们一起是美丽、接地气的一对，深深致力于赋予叙利亚公民和叙利亚公民社会权力。两年后，阿萨德政权对自己的同胞使用了化学武器。或者考虑这一点。
Decades earlier, various international newspapers wrote about the domestic life of a well-known leader. Readers learned the interior spaces of his Bavarian retreat were painted in various shades of green. There was a portrait of his mother in his bedroom. He breakfasted on milk, bread, honey, oatmeal, and cheese. They talk about his vegetarianism, they talk about his dogs and how much he loves his dogs and his dogs love him. They talk about how much he loves children. The man was Adolf Hitler. In her book, Hitler at Home, the Spina Stratigacos explores how the Nazi propaganda machine created an image of Hitler as a humble
几十年前，各大国际报纸都报道过一位知名领导人的家庭生活。读者了解到，他巴伐利亚隐居之所的内部空间被漆成各种色调的绿色。他的卧室里挂着他母亲的画像。他的早餐吃的是牛奶、面包、蜂蜜、燕麦片和奶酪。他们谈论他的素食主义，他们谈论他的狗以及他多么爱他的狗，他的狗也多么爱他。他们谈论他多么喜爱儿童。这个人就是阿道夫·希特勒。斯皮纳·斯特拉蒂加科斯在她的书《家中的希特勒》中探讨了纳粹宣传机器是如何将希特勒塑造为一个谦逊的、
man of the people at ease in nature. In 1937, the New York Times magazine featured a sympathetic glimpse of Hitler living in the mountains, thinking about the destiny of his nation. Shockingly, after this 1937 New York Times article, there is absolute puff piece that appears on August 20th, 1939 in the New York Times again. And that one has absolutely no critical edge to it. It is by a woman who I haven't been able to identify, who talks about the fact that Hitler loves Gooseberry Pie and how wonderful the tomatoes are on its table. And it appears, you know, just less than two weeks before Hitler invades Poland.
大自然中泰然自若的平民领袖形象的。1937年，《纽约时报杂志》刊登了一篇充满同情心的报道，展示了希特勒隐居山间、思考国家命运的生活。令人震惊的是，在这篇1937年的《纽约时报》文章之后，1939年8月20日，《纽约时报》又刊登了一篇绝对是吹捧的文章。那篇文章完全没有批判性。它出自一位我未能确认身份的女性之手，文中谈到希特勒喜欢醋栗派，以及他餐桌上的西红柿是多么美味。这篇文章发表的时间，你知道的，就在希特勒入侵波兰前不到两周。
Gooseberry Pie, a photo of a waterskin in Kennedy, a president grooming his horses like a cowboy. What these images do is say, don't worry, I may be powerful, but I haven't lost touch with you. We're still connected. We're the same. Thousands of miles from the Bavarian Alps, Taurus and Hollywood are balancing the twin impulses we have toward the rich and powerful. As the tour winds through the Hollywood hills, it comes to a stop, a new one. And whether you hit the new president or you love him, I could just tell you this. This is his house on the right-hand side.
醋栗派、肯尼迪玩水的照片、像牛仔一样梳理马匹的总统。这些形象传达的信息是：别担心，我可能很有权力，但我并没有与你们脱节。我们依然相连。我们是一样的。距离巴伐利亚阿尔卑斯山数千英里之外，好莱坞的导游们正在平衡我们对富豪和权贵那双重冲动。当旅行团穿过好莱坞山时，它停了下来，这是一个新的停靠点。无论你是痛恨新总统还是热爱他，我只想告诉你这一点。这是他在右侧的房子。
This is Donald J. Trump's winter estate here in Beverly Hills right here on the right-hand side, the house there. And we're going to pop the pools right there. It's the tiniest little pool. Yeah. And here's the servants' quarters back here. Donald Trump's election has ignited the contradictory feelings we have toward the rich and powerful.
这是唐纳德·特朗普在比弗利山庄的冬季度假别墅，就在右边，那栋房子。我们这就把游泳池拍下来。这是一个极其微小的泳池。是的。这里是后面的仆人房。唐纳德·特朗普的当选点燃了我们对富豪和权贵的矛盾情感。
To his critics, Donald Trump has broken with the precedent of modesty set by many leaders. He's rich, he's powerful, he's famous, and he flaunts it. In the language of evolutionary anthropology, he is the boastful hunter in the tribe. But to his supporters, he is very much a man of the people, someone who's promised to level the playing field, a populist. Today, the political world orbits around him. Congressman and heads of state, tiptoe around criticisms, careful not to go too far. But you can be sure of this, even among his supporters, there are people ready to pounce
在批评者眼里，唐纳德·特朗普打破了许多领导人树立的谦逊先例。他富有、有权、有名，并且毫不掩饰。用演化人类学的话来说，他就是部落里那个爱吹嘘的猎人。但在支持者眼里，他非常平易近人，是一个承诺创造公平竞争环境的民粹主义者。今天，政治世界围绕着他运转。国会议员和国家元首在批评时小心翼翼，生怕过头。但你可以确信这一点，即使在他的支持者中，也有人在寻找机会，在出现第一丝软弱迹象时猛扑过去。
at the first sign of weakness. When we come back, we're going to look at the other side of power, how people become powerful and what power does to them once they get there. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. This week on the show, we're exploring dynamics of power, from the evolutionary roots of our ambivalence toward it. Basically, if you look at the individual chimpanzees and how they behave around their superiors, it's rather ambivalent. To how people become powerful, and what power does to them once they have it.
稍后回来，我们将审视权力的另一面，人们是如何变得强大的，以及一旦他们拥有了权力，权力会对他们做什么。这里是《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本周节目中，我们将探讨权力的动力学，从我们对权力抱有矛盾心理的进化根源——基本上，如果你观察单个黑猩猩以及它们在显贵周围的行为，就会发现这相当矛盾——到人们如何获得权力，以及一旦拥有权力，权力会对他们产生什么影响。
Power does make us a little bit more self-focused, but this can happen to us all. This is just what the mind does when we feel powerful. When you think of a powerful person, what comes to mind? Knowledge is power. Seize him. Cauties throat. Shows like Game of Thrones tell us, exerting power means harming other people, or at least threatening to.
权力确实会让我们稍微更加关注自我，但这可能会发生在每个人身上。这只是当我们感到自己有权力时大脑的自然反应。当你想到一个有权势的人时，你会想到什么？知识就是力量。抓住他。割断喉咙。像《权力的游戏》这样的剧集告诉我们，行使权力意味着伤害他人，或者至少是发出这种威胁。
But the research at Docker Calvina suggests that it's actually kind and empathetic behavior that leads people to power. It's what happens once they get there, that's the problem. Dacker, welcome to Hidden Brain. It's great to be with you, Shankar. I'm fascinated by the research that you cite in the book, Dacker, that suggests that power shapes nearly all of our relationships. If you put a bunch of 13-year-old kids in a room, you say that power dynamics quickly
但达克·卡尔维纳的研究表明，实际上是善良和富有同理心的行为引导人们走向权力。问题在于他们一旦掌权后会发生什么。达克，欢迎来到《隐藏的大脑》。很高兴能和你在一起，尚卡尔。达克，你书中所引用的研究让我着迷，这些研究表明权力塑造了我们几乎所有的关系。如果你把一群13岁的孩子放在一个房间里，你会发现权力动力学迅速
emerge, and you make the case that kids who are kinder and more empathetic are the ones who quickly assume the matter of power in the group. So you're right on both counts, Shankar. First of all, one of the things that we've learned in the science of power is that really power dynamics, who's influencing whom, shape every relationship from parent child dynamics to dynamics in the US Senate. And then, you know, what we've discovered over the past 20 years is probably a little bit counterintuitive,
显现，你提出这样的观点：更善良、更有同理心的孩子是那些在群体中迅速掌握权力的人。你的两点看法都是对的，尚卡尔。首先，我们在权力科学中了解到的事情之一是，真正的权力动力学（谁在影响谁）塑造了每一种关系，从亲子动力学到美国参议院的动力学。然后，你知道的，我们在过去20年中发现的可能有点违反直觉，
and it challenges older ideas about power, more Machuvellian ideas. And what the science is finding is that kids at school, kids in summer camps, people in colleges, people in organizations, if they are emotionally intelligent and really focus on others and even practice generosity they rise in social power. I have to say it's like here that I have some skepticism and this might be because you attended nicer schools than I did but my experience of
它挑战了关于权力的陈旧观念，即更倾向于马基雅维利式的观念。科学发现的是，学校里的孩子、夏令营里的孩子、大学里的人、组织里的人，如果他们具有情商，真正关注他人甚至践行慷慨，他们就会在社会权力中上升。我必须说，我在这里有点怀疑，这可能是因为你去的学校比我好，但我在初中的经历，
middle school felt you know more emotionally like the Hunger Games. I'm volunteers tribute! I'll tribute Pita Malarque as Cat Miss Ebony. They just want a good show. That's all they want. It's 24th of a scale and the one comes out. I mean, is my experience an aberration? Well, I don't know where you went to school, but it tends to be an aberration. You know, so what these studies do is they take a group of 7th graders. my experience in aberration? Well, I don't know where you went to school, but it tends to be an aberration. So what these studies do is they take a group of seventh graders.
从情感上感觉更像是《饥饿游戏》。我自愿参加！我将皮塔·麦拉克奉献给凯特尼斯·埃夫丁。他们只是想看一场好戏。他们想要的仅此而已。这是24分之一的比例，而其中一人能胜出。我的经历是个例外吗？嗯，我不知道你在哪里上学，但那往往是个例外。所以，这些研究所做的是，他们找了一组7年级的学生。我的经历是个例外吗？嗯，我不知道你在哪里上学，但那往往是个例外。所以，这些研究所做的是，他们找了一组七年级的学生。
You find out who has respect in a steam at the start of the year. You study what their social behaviors are, their social strategies, and then you track how they do in the hierarchy of that seventh grade class to use your example. And what you find is, is yes the bullies and the Machiavellians, the sociopaths, they get a little bit of attention early, but over the long haul, and this is true in other contexts, they don't have as much power as they would like to, and instead what studies find now numbering in the
你找出学年初谁获得了尊重和声望。你研究他们的社会行为、社会策略，然后以你的例子追踪他们在那个七年级班级等级制度中的表现。你发现的是，是的，霸凌者、马基雅维利主义者、反社会者，他们在早期会得到一点关注，但从长远来看——这在其他语境下也是真的——他们并没有获得他们想要的那么多权力，相反，现在数量已达数十项的研究发现，
dozens, it's it's really the connecting kid, the empathetic kid, the kid who's really open and curious who really rises in the esteem and the ranks of the class. I'm wondering if this really comes down to thinking about power in two different ways. The power that I'm hearing you talk about is really reputational power. I think of doctors without borders, for example, is having reputational power. They don't cut my paycheck and they can't fire me, but I pay attention to what they say because I respect them as an organization. On the other hand, when you have coercive power, people who can punish you or people who
真正提升班级声望和排名的，其实是那些善于连接他人、富有同理心、真正开放且好奇的孩子。我想知道这是否真的归结为以两种不同的方式看待权力。我听到你谈论的权力实际上是声誉权力。例如，我认为无国界医生组织拥有声誉权力。他们不发给我工资，也无法解雇我，但我关注他们说的话，因为我作为一个组织尊重他们。另一方面，当你拥有强制性权力，即那些可以惩罚你或可以夺走你生命或自由的人时，感觉可能是——有没有可能这两种不同的权力路径对应着这两种不同类型的权力？
can take away your life or your freedom, it feels like maybe is it possible that those two different, there are two different paths to power for those two different kinds of power? Absolutely. That's a wonderful observation. One of the things that the science of power is Absolutely, and that's a wonderful observation. And so one of the things that the science of power is done, which I report on in the power paradox, is to take a step back and think,
绝对是的。这是一个极好的观察。权力科学所做的事情之一是：绝对是的，这是一个极好的观察。因此，我在《权力悖论》一书中报道的权力科学所做的事情之一，就是退一步思考，
what do we really mean by power? We intuitively define it as money, but a lot of things happen in the world that are independent of capital. We might think of it historically as military might, but you can easily come up with counter examples where immense military might actually produces weakness. And so we have to kind of problematize it and what the field has done is
我们对权力的真正定义是什么？我们凭直觉将它定义为金钱，但世界上发生的很多事情都与资本无关。我们可能会在历史上认为它是军事力量，但你很容易举出反例，说明巨大的军事力量实际上会产生软弱。因此，我们必须对它进行问题化，而这个领域所做的是
thought about one strategy to power that works in certain contexts is a kind of a coercive top down Machiavellian strategy. Another kind is a more socially intelligent strategy that involves some of these things we've been talking about. And you know what's really interesting, Sean Kern, one of the things that inspired me to write this book is a lot of data that have been summarized by people like Alice Eglie, finding that our conception of power is moving from coercive strategies to more collaborative strategies. So it's one of the reasons I wrote this book. So when you describe this kind of power
思考一种在某些环境中行之有效的权力策略，即一种强制性的、自上而下的、马基雅维利式的策略。另一种则是更具社会智能的策略，涉及我们一直在讨论的一些事情。你知道吗，尚卡尔，激发我写这本书的原因之一，是爱丽丝·埃格利等人总结的大量数据，他们发现我们对权力的概念正在从强制性策略转向更多协作性策略。所以这也是我写这本书的原因之一。因此，当你描述这种
that is more reputational, by that account, you would say, you know, the United States's power in the world is not just a reflection of the strength of its military and the size of its armed forces. It's really about the power of its ideas, its ability to do well in the world. Is that the argument you're making that this kind of soft power in some ways is more important than the hard power that we've come to associate with power?
更具声誉的权力时，根据这种说法，你会说，美国在世界上的权力不仅反映在其军事实力和武装部队的规模上。它实际上关乎其思想的力量、其在世界上做好事的能力。这就是你所提出的观点吗？即在某些方面，这种软实力比我们以往与权力联系在一起的硬实力更重要？
Well, this is one of the ideas that really spurred the science of power in our lab and other labs for the past 20 years, which is that, you know, if you think about the influence the U.S. has on the average world citizen, part of it is through the flow of capital and economics and part of it is, you know, having this expansive military. But a bigger component or dimension to our power is how do we shape the thinking of people around the world? How do we shape the emotions of people around the world? Are there what they deem to be fair or right? And that comes through books, it comes through forms of art, it comes through journalism.
嗯，这是在过去20年中激发我们实验室和其他实验室进行权力科学研究的想法之一，也就是说，如果你想想美国对普通世界公民的影响，部分是通过资本和经济的流动实现的，部分是通过拥有这种庞大的军队实现的。但对我们权力的更大组成部分或维度是，我们如何塑造世界各地人们的思想？我们如何塑造世界各地人们的情感？什么是他们认为公平或正确的事？这通过书籍、艺术形式、新闻来实现。
I have today signed an executive order providing for the establishment of a peace call on a temple. As the greatest demonstration for freedom in the history of our nation. If there is one message that echoes forth from this conference, let it be that human rights, our women's rights, and women's rights, our human rights once and for all. Thank you. For too long, women have not been heard or believed.
我今天签署了一项行政命令，规定在坦佩建立和平队。作为我们国家历史上争取自由的最伟大展示。如果这次会议能发出一个回响的信号，那就是人权就是妇女权利，妇女权利就是人权，一劳永逸。谢谢。长久以来，女性的声音没有被听到，也没有被相信。
If they dared to speak their truth to the power of those men, but their time is up. You know, I took that thinking of soft power, if you will, which is in some ways harder, and really extended it to the personal realm, which is that as a parent, you know, yeah, I have economic control over my kids, I have, I'm bigger than they are. But really, I also influence them through ideas, through preferences that I enable, through the context that I put them in. So, power is much more than economic or military might. It's really, it's how we influence the states of other
如果她们敢于向那些男人的权力说出真相，那么他们的时间就到了。你知道，我把那种关于软力的思考（如果你愿意的话，它在某些方面其实更难）真正延伸到了个人领域，也就是说，作为父母，是的，我对我的孩子有经济控制权，我有，我比他们体型更大。但实际上，我也通过思想、我促成的偏好、我为他们创造的环境来影响他们。因此，权力远不止经济或军事力量。实际上，它是我们如何影响其他人状态的方式。
people. You're talking the book about the... the story of Abraham Lincoln and side his rights to power is as a classic example of what you're talking about the skills that you're talking about yeah you know one of the things i did chanker you know in the three years of writing this book and really while i've been doing the science of power is just to read broadly on the biographies of great leaders, the historical accounts of important
你在书中谈到了……亚伯拉罕·林肯的故事，他通往权力的道路正是你所谈论的技能的典型例子，对吧？是的，你知道我做的一件事，尚卡尔，在写这本书的三年来，以及真正从事权力科学研究的同时，就是广泛阅读伟大领导人的传记、重要社会变革的历史记载。你知道我一次又一次遇到的是，有这些例子，非常有说服力的伟大领导人的例子，他们通过推进其他人的利益来进行领导。你知道，亚伯拉罕·林肯就是一个非常有说服力的例子。我喜欢瑟洛·韦德对他的这种观察，瑟洛·韦德是当时的一位记者，也是林肯时代政治的密切研究者。他说，林肯究竟有什么特点，解释了他那不可预测的权力崛起？一个穷小子，笨拙，没有通常能赋予你权力的种种优势。他说，瑟洛·韦德说，林肯会见并倾听每一个来找他的人。他只是全心投入到他人的利益中。
social change. And you know what I encountered is time and time again that there are these examples, very compelling examples of great leaders who lead through advancing the interests of other people. You know, I mean Abraham Lincoln was such a compelling example. I love this observation about him of Thurlow Weed, who was a journalist at the time, a close student of the politics of Lincoln's era. He's like, what is it about Lincoln that accounts for his really unpredictable rise in powers? A poor guy, awkward, didn't have all the advantages that often give you power. And he said, Thurloweed said, you know, Lincoln sees and hears everybody who comes to him. He just engages in the interests of others.
当我读到这个，然后又听到关于斯蒂芬·科特的研究时——该研究显示，正是职场中那些高情商的管理者在职级上不断攀升并建立起强大的团队——我看到了证据之间美好的交汇。我们马上回来。欢迎收听《隐藏的大脑》，我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆。本周我们探讨的是权力：我们对它的矛盾情感、我们如何获得权力，以及当我们拥有权力后它对我们做了什么。记住，能力越大，责任越大。
And then when I read that and then I heard about the science, for example, of Stefan Kote showing it's really these emotionally intelligent managers in workplaces that rise in the ranks and build strong teams. I saw this nice convergence of evidence. We'll be right back. You're listening to Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedanthan. This week we're talking about power, how we feel ambivalent toward it, how we attain it, and what power does to us once we have it. Remember, with great power, comes great responsibility.
你害怕我会变成某种罪犯吗？别为我担心了，好吗？你穿着运动裤。今天是我的日子。所以，这违反了规则，你不能和我们坐在一起。权力确实会让我们稍微更加关注自我，但这可能会发生在每个人身上。这只是当我们感到自己有权力时大脑的自然反应。
Are you afraid that I'm going to turn into some kind of criminal? Quit worrying about me, okay? You're wearing sweatpants. It's my day. So, so that's against the rules, and you can't sit with us. Power does make us a little bit more self-focused, but this can happen to us all. This is just what the mind does when we feel powerful.
达克·卡特纳是加州大学伯克利分校的研究员。他研究权力，并且发现了一个关于感到强大如何影响我们所有人的令人不安的现象。嗯，这是我们进行的一些更具戏剧性的工作，现在已经在许多不同的地方得到了重复验证。这也是为什么我将这本书命名为《权力悖论》，也就是说，如果你看看权力的社会科学，我们通过我们天生具有的亲社会倾向获得权力，但一旦我们感到强大，或者我们来自特权背景
Docker Katner is a researcher at the University of California at Berkeley. He studies power, and he's found something disturbing about the way feeling powerful affects us all. Well, this was some of the more dramatic work that we engaged in, that's now been replicated in a lot of different places. And that's why I call the Book the Power Paradox, which is, if you look at this social science of power, we get power through the pro-social tendencies that we are endowed with, but then once we feel powerful, or we come from a background of privilege
并且感觉自己高人一等，我们就会失去这些倾向。让我给你举个例子。有很多研究表明，同理心实践能为你带来权力的提升。我最喜欢的一个例子是威廉·科利奇的研究，研究表明，当你给团队这些复杂的难题去解决时，正是那些更具同理心的个体让团队变得更强大、表现得更好。他们善于倾听，提出好的问题，关注他人。所以同理心让团队和个人都变得更强大。
and feeling above others, we lose those tendencies. So let me give you an example. There are a lot of studies that show that empathetic practices get you power. So one of my favorites is work by William College showing, you give teams these complex problems to solve. It's really the more empathetic individuals that make their team stronger and perform better, right? They're listening well, they're asking good questions, they're paying attention to other people. So empathy makes the team and the individual stronger.
并且感觉自己高人一等，我们就会失去这些倾向。所以让我给你们举个例子。有很多研究表明，同理心实践能为你带来力量。因此，我最喜欢的研究之一是威廉学院（William College）的工作，研究表明，当你让团队解决这些复杂问题时，正是那些更有同理心的个人使他们的团队更强大、表现更好，对吧？他们善于倾听，善于提出好问题，善于关注他人。因此，同理心使团队和个人变得更加强大。
And then what we started to show in our lab is once we feel powerful, or our capacity to empathize and to know what others are thinking really is diminished. So in one study, really simple, we get bring people to the lab, we have them engage in this exercise where they compare themselves to the real poor people of society and it makes them feel powerful. Or they compare themselves to the kind of the elite of society and they feel as a result of that comparison less power. And then we just present them some photos of people expressing different emotions with subtle muscle movements around the eyes, like concentration or flirtatious or decisive. And what we find is when you feel powerful, you lose your ability to read emotion
然后在我们的实验室里，我们开始发现，一旦我们感到自己很有权力，我们同理他人以及理解他人想法的能力实际上就会减弱。所以在的一项研究中，非常简单，我们把人们带到实验室，让他们进行这样一项练习：将自己与社会上真正的穷人进行比较，这会让他们觉得自己很有权力。或者他们把自己与社会上的精英进行比较，结果因为这种比较而觉得自己权力较小。接着，我们向他们展示了一些人的照片，这些人通过眼睛周围微妙的肌肉运动来表达不同的情绪，比如专注、调情或果断。我们发现，当你感到自己有权力时，你就失去了识别情绪的能力
in people's facial expressions. Why would that happen? Well, I mean, there are a couple of deep reasons. One is, you know, this is just striking research by Keely Mescatel and Superindiru OB, which is that, you know, Shankar, if I feel powerful, the studies show, I just feel less interested in other people, less invested in them, and as a result, the empathy networks in the brain are actually quieted. They're less active. So, Keely Muscatel brought people to the lab. She had them sort of think about another student's daily life. And if you come from a position of privilege and power, the classic empathy networks in the frontal lobes
在人们的面部表情中。为什么会这样？嗯，我的意思是，有几个深层的原因。其中之一是，你知道，这是凯利·梅斯卡特尔（Keely Mescatel）和苏佩里杜·奥布（Superindiru OB）一项引人注目的研究，那就是，你知道，尚卡尔（Shankar），如果我感到自己有权力，研究表明，我就会对其他人感到不那么感兴趣，对他们的投入减少，因此，大脑中的同理心网络实际上变得安静了。它们的活跃度降低了。所以，凯利·穆斯卡特尔把人们带到了实验室。她让他们思考另一个学生的日常生活。如果你来自享有特权和权力的地位，前额叶皮层中经典的同理心网络
of your brain are not even active when you're thinking about another student. So this is a very deep effect of what power does to our empathic capacities. So what you're saying in some ways is that we are empathetic to others in part because that's useful to us. We lack power in many many situations and being empathetic and being aware of others allows us to navigate our social worlds effectively. But when we perceive ourselves having power and privilege, in some ways, we don't need to depend as much as we do on others. We don't need to reach out to others. And so those networks shut down. Yeah, no really well put because if you think about, for example, somebody who's poor and doesn't have a lot of resources,
当你在思考另一个学生时，你大脑中的这些网络甚至都不会活跃。所以这是权力对我们的同理心能力所产生的非常深远的影响。所以你从某种程度上说，我们在一定程度上对他人感同身受，是因为这对我们有用。我们在许多许多情况下都缺乏权力，而富有同理心并对他人保持觉察，能让我们有效地在社交世界中导航。但当我们感知到自己拥有权力和特权时，在某种程度上，我们就不需要像以前那样依赖他人了。我们不需要向他人伸出援手。因此，那些网络就关闭了。是的，这话说的真的很好，因为如果你想想，例如，一个贫穷且没有多少资源的人，
they're dependent on other people to get to work, to do a little bit of, you know, ad hoc child care or what have you. So you're dependent on others and out of that state of mutual dependence, you really, with vigilance, attend to other people and are aware of what they're doing. And that produces these empathy benefits coming out of less power. And then the compliment, you lose that empathy when you feel less dependent on others and powerful. So one of the paradoxes of this is something that you and others have identified, which
他们依赖其他人去上班，去做一点，你知道的，临时的育儿工作等等。所以你依赖他人，出于这种相互依赖的状态，你确实会带着警惕性去关注他人，并意识到他们在做什么。这产生了源自较低权力的同理心收益。随之而来的反面是，当你觉得不再那么依赖他人、并且很有权力时，你就会失去这种同理心。所以这里的悖论之一，就是你和其他人所指出的那种现象，即
is to look at the generosity of people who are rich and poor, and you find some really surprising things. Yeah, you know, so again, so again, what studies are finding, and again, this is part of the power paradox, which is that there is this really interesting literature called competitive altruism, and if you take the average person in a social network, and they practice generosity and they share resources
去审视富人和穷人的慷慨程度，你会发现一些非常令人惊讶的事情。是的，你知道，所以再次，所以再次，研究发现，这也是权力悖论的一部分，即存在一个非常有趣的文献，称为竞争性利他主义，如果你把社交网络中的普通人拿出来，他们实践慷慨并分享资源
or they encourage others, through those acts of generosity, they rise in power. People trust them, they esteem them. You even see this in hunter-gatherer societies where it's really the individual who shares the most food in the hunter-gatherer societies who rises in the ranks. And yet, what we started to find with Paul Piff and other colleagues is once I feel powerful,
或者他们鼓励他人，通过这些慷慨的行为，他们的权力地位会上升。人们信任他们，尊重他们。你甚至在狩猎采集社会中也能看到这一点，在狩猎采集社会中，真正分享最多食物的个人往往会在等级制度中上升。然而，我们与保罗·皮夫（Paul Piff）和其他同事开始发现的是，一旦我感到自己很有权力，
I proved to be less generous. So in one study, we brought people to lab who varied in terms of their social class and family wealth. We just gave them a very simple opportunity to share resources with a stranger. And we found it was really the poor who shared more and higher power people, more privileged people shared less. Now, obviously, people who are millionaires and billionaires, they might be philanthropic and they might give larger amounts of money.
我就会表现得不那么慷慨。所以在的一项研究中，我们把在社会阶层和家庭财富方面各不相同的受试者带到实验室。我们只是给他们一个非常简单的机会，与陌生人分享资源。我们发现，真正分享更多的是穷人，而权力更高的人、更有特权的人分享得更少。现在，显然，百万富翁和亿万富翁们可能会做慈善，他们可能会捐出更多的钱。
But what you're really saying is it's a proportion of your wealth for a millionaire to give a thousand dollars is not the same thing as somebody at the poverty line who's giving 50. Yeah, we always have to be careful about how we interpret these results. And these are just, you know, proportions of sharing and not absolute amounts, and you're absolutely right. But you even get this experimentally. So, you know, in one of our early studies in power, we were interested in, does experimentally
但你真正要说的是，这是财富的一个比例，对于百万富翁来说捐出一千美元，与处于贫困线的人捐出五十美元是不同的概念。是的，我们在如何解释这些结果时必须始终小心谨慎。这些都只是，你知道的，分享的比例，而不是绝对数量，你是完全正确的。但你甚至可以通过实验来得出这一点。所以，你知道，在我们早期关于权力的研究中，我们感兴趣的是，通过实验
produce power lead to kind of the hoarding of resources which we've been talking about. We brought groups of three people to the lab. We randomly signed one individual to the position of power. And then by design, they went through this experiment and was kind of boring and they're writing policies for the university. And we brought in halfway through this study, this plate of five chocolate chip cookies. Every member of the group, three people all together, a cookie and so we asked who took that fourth cookie. And it was our high-power person who tended to take that cookie. Not only that,
产生的权力是否会导致我们一直在讨论的资源囤积？我们将三个人为一组带到实验室。我们随机指派其中一个人担任权力职位。然后按照设计，他们经历了这个实验，这有点无聊，他们正在为大学撰写政策。在这个研究进行到一半时，我们拿来了一盘五块巧克力曲奇。组里的每个成员，总共三个人，拿了一块曲奇，然后我们问是谁拿了第四块曲奇。结果往往是我们那个处于高权力的人拿了那块曲奇。不仅如此，
but they ate in this kind of impulsive way where their lips were smacking, mouths were open. Crumbs, we took it seven months ago, the crumbs falling on their sweaters. And again, you know what this tells us is really two things, Shankar, which is, you know, power does make us a little bit more self-focused. In this, you know, you're sharing less, you're keeping more for yourself, you're eating the cookie in an impulsive way. But the other thing I think we shouldn't lose sight of is this can happen to us all, right? This is just what the mind does when we feel powerful. Because of course these were just random people who are brought into the lab and you've randomly picked one of them to assign them a feeling of power. Yeah, absolutely. You did mention there were five cookies and three people,
而且他们以一种冲动的方式吃着，咂着嘴，嘴巴张开。碎屑——我们在七个月前做的实验——碎屑落在他们的毛衣上。再次，你知道这告诉我们实际上有两件事，尚卡尔，那就是，你知道，权力确实让我们变得更加以自我为中心。在这个过程中，你知道，你分享得更少了，你为自己保留得更多了，你以一种冲动的方式吃曲奇。但另一件我认为我们不应该忽视的事情是，这可能会发生在每个人身上，对吧？当我们的感到有权力时，这只是大脑的自然反应。因为当然这些只是被带到实验室的随机人员，而你随机挑选了其中一个人来赋予他们一种权力感。是的，绝对的。你确实提到有五块曲奇和三个人，
so what happened to the fifth cookie? Well this was where it was really interesting because you know the rules of politeness suggest that you really should not be that uncouth person who takes the last cookie off the plate. And so we did pilot testing for the experiment and no one would take that fourth cookie. So that's why we added a fifth cookie just to free somebody up to take that second the last cookie. So it's fascinating because of course what you see in these lab experiments is often reflected on much, much bigger stages where you see people in power abusing that power, you know, having affairs, cheating, and you know, falsifying financial returns. And you know, at one level, the conventional view, I think, is sort of say, these are just
那么第五块曲奇怎么了？嗯，这就是真正有趣的地方，因为你知道礼貌规则表明，你真的不应该成为那个拿起盘子里最后一块曲奇的不知礼节的人。所以我们为实验进行了预测试，没有人会拿第四块曲奇。这就是为什么我们加了第五块曲奇，只是为了解放某个人去拿倒数第二块曲奇。所以这很迷人，因为当然你在这些实验室实验中看到的情况，往往反映在更大得多的舞台上，在那里你会看到掌权者滥用权力，你知道的，搞外遇、作弊，还有，你知道的，伪造财务回报。你知道，在一个层面，传统的观点，我认为，可以说是，这些只是
people who were bad people who rose to the top. But what you're suggesting is actually something more complex and in some ways much sadder, which is that these might not be bad people who rose to the top, but these might be good people who rose to the top and power has made them bad. Yeah, I mean, that's such a very compelling and sweeping statement about this shanker, you know, that does align with how I read this social scientific evidence, which is that there are dozens of experiments where we randomly assign typical people to either positions of power or less
爬到顶层时本身就是坏人的人。但你所暗示的其实是更复杂的事情，在某些方面要悲伤得多，那就是这些人可能不是爬到顶层的坏人，而是爬到顶层的好人，而权力使他们变坏了。是的，我的意思是，这是一个非常引人注目且全面的关于这一点的陈述，尚卡尔，你知道，这确实符合我阅读社会科学证据的方式，即有几十个实验，我们将普通人随机分配到权力职位或较少
power, and you find these patterns where, if I'm just randomly given power. And I feel this sense of sort of expansive euphoria that comes with power and a sense of omnipotence. You know, I speak more rudely. I take resources that are meant for somebody else. I'm more likely to flirt inappropriately. I'm more likely to engage in inappropriate sexual behavior. We have studies showing when you make somebody feel powerful. You're more likely to cheat at a game to win 50 bucks. The list goes on, and it really lends credence to Lord Acton's old observation
权力的职位中，你会发现这些模式：如果我只是被随机赋予了权力，我感到了伴随权力而来的那种扩张性的欣快感和一种无所不能的感觉。你知道，我说话更粗鲁了。我拿走了原本属于别人的资源。我更有可能不恰当的调情。我更有可能从事不恰当的性行为。我们的研究表明，当你让某人感到有权力时，你在游戏中为了赢取五十块钱而作弊的可能性就会增加。这样的例子不胜枚举，这确实印证了阿克顿勋爵（Lord Acton）的经典观察
that I think stands the test of time, which is power corrupts and absolute power corrupts absolutely. You've also found the same thing looking at drivers of various cars. I understand you ran an experiment where you stood outside an intersection and saw who stopped at a stop sign. I remember one day I was biking to work and I almost got hit by a black Mercedes and the guy, you know, and I was in the riot, I sort of waited and gone through this faraway stop, area in California. And this guy plowed and almost hit me and he looked at me as if, you know, I was the
我认为这经受住了时间的考验，那就是权力导致腐败，绝对权力绝对腐败。你在观察各种汽车的驾驶员时也发现了同样的现象。我了解到你曾做过一个实验，你站在一个十字路口外面，看谁在停车标志前停车。我记得有一天我骑自行车去上班，差点被一辆黑色奔驰撞倒，那家伙，你知道的，而我在右边，我算是等了一下，穿过了这个远处的停车区域，在加利福尼亚州。这家伙猛冲过来，差点撞到我，他看着我，就好像，你知道的，我是
Hoy Pulo and should be sort of taken off the road. And I thought, you know, it'd be really interesting to test these ideas about the impulsive actions that power produces by looking at people drive. So what we did in one of the versions of this study is we put a young Berkeley undergraduate at a pedestrian zone right next to the Berkeley campus. The pedestrian zone is this strip that cuts across the road that gives the pedestrian the right of way. You get to cross the road.
下层阶级，应该被赶出路面一样。我想，你知道的，通过观察人们的驾驶方式来测试关于权力产生冲动行为的这些想法，会非常有趣。所以在该研究的一个版本中，我们在紧邻伯克利校园的一个行人区安插了一名年轻的伯克利本科生。行人区是穿过道路、赋予行人通行权的那条地带。你可以过马路。
It's white stripes. And then we coded, and we had these Berkeley undergrads kind of heighted in the bushes. One student was standing at the pedestrian zone. The other student who was coding was noting the make of the car. And weather, very simply, did they stop for the pedestrian, which is law? Or did they blaze through the pedestrian zone? And 0% of our drivers have poor cars, the Ugo's and Plymouth satellites of the world
那是白色的斑马线。然后我们进行编码，我们的伯克利本科生隐藏在灌木丛中。一个学生站在行人区。另一个负责编码的学生则在记录车型。以及天气，非常简单，他们是否为行人停车，这是法律规定？还是他们呼啸着穿过了行人区？我们的驾驶员中，开廉价车的占了0%，像尤戈（Yugo）和普利茅斯卫星（Plymouth Satellite）这样的车
drove through the pedestrian zone, 46.2% of our drivers of wealthy cars, you know, the Mercedes and the like drive through the pedestrian zone. 46%? Is this something to do with Berkeley? You know, it's funny. I just got a letter from a guy in Germany who was like, this would not happen in Germany where we really value our Mercedes and BMWs. You know, we've replicated it. It's been replicated in other states. It led people to email me from all manner of context. One of my favorites was a prehistriver email me and said, well, you know, that's Mercedes, but of course, prehistrivers abide by the law.
直接开过了行人区，而开豪车的驾驶员中有46.2%，你知道的，比如奔驰之类的车，直接开过了行人区。46%？这和伯克利有什么关系吗？你知道，这很有趣。我刚收到一个德国人的信，他好像在说，这在德国是不会发生的，在德国我们真的很珍视我们的奔驰和宝马。你知道，我们已经重复了这项实验。它在其他州也被重复了。这引得各种各样背景的人发电子邮件给我。我最喜欢的一封是，一个披萨外卖员发邮件给我说，好吧，你知道，那是奔驰，但当然，披萨外卖员是遵守法律的。
So we checked and prehistrivers were actually the worst. So you know, and this just fits this larger profile that I'm sure your listeners are aware of, that there's something about the seductions of power that makes you lose sight of ethics and other people's interests. You're talking the book about leaders who are able to overcome the paradox of power. And we talked earlier about Lincoln and how his rise to power was marked by demonstrations of these positive behaviors. But you also write about how he was able to retain a sense of that kinder gentler, more empathetic self, even as he acquired and wielded great power, talk
所以我们进行了核实，而披萨外卖员实际上是最糟糕的。所以，你知道的，这正好符合我确信你们的听众也知道的那个更大的特点，即权力的诱惑有某种魔力，会让你忽视道德和他人的利益。你在书中谈到了那些能够克服权力悖论的领导者。我们早些时候谈到了林肯，以及他如何崛起为权力拥有者，其标志是展现出这些积极的行为。但你也写到了他是如何保持那种更善良、更温柔、更有同理心的自我意识的，即使在他获得并挥舞巨大权力的时候，谈谈
about that story and what he did that might be illustrated for the rest of us. Well, I think that the thing that really is striking about Lincoln's power is, you know, he had a short presidency, but he remained focused on the interests of others. He remained focused on uniting disparate parties and really the greater good, if you will, that he knew that there was this state of the union that he was heading toward. And the way that he did it, you know, is, and that just comes through, for example, in Doris Kern's good ones, team of rivals, is, he just, he kept close to not only the dignity
这个故事以及他所做的事情，这些可能会对我们其他人有所启示。嗯，我认为关于林肯的权力，真正引人注目的是，你知道，他经历了一个短暂的总统任期，但他始终专注于他人的利益。他始终专注于团结不同的政党，可以说是为了更广泛的共同利益，他知道自己正朝着一个国家团结的状态前进。而他做到这一点的方式，你知道，就是，这正如多丽丝·库恩斯·古德温（Doris Kearns Goodwin）的《团队之争》（Team of Rivals）中所展现的那样，他只是，他不仅与每个人保持密切联系
of everybody and treated, you know, the warring sides, if you will, with respect. But he also, and I think this is really important, is that he sort of kept close to, you know, the suffering that was involved, and what the costs and stakes were. And that was really foundational to his power. And what you see in a lot of the great leaders
的尊严，并以尊重对待交战双方，如果你愿意这么说的话。而且他还——我认为这真的很重要——他与所涉及的痛苦，以及代价和利害关系保持密切联系。这确实是他权力的基础。你在许多伟大的领导者身上看到的是
is this really commitment to the greater good and the concept of respect and the needs of others. You know, Daco, you and I have talked before, and as I was reading the book, I remembered something that you had told me in the past, which is you didn't grow up with a lot of power and privilege. And to some extent, you now have some of those things. And I'm wondering if you can talk about your own journey and how your own journey may have changed you and whether you see yourself
对共同利益的真正承诺，以及尊重和他人需求的概念。你知道，达科（Daco），你和我以前交谈过，当我读这本书时，我想起了你过去对我说过的一些话，那就是你成长过程中并没有很多权力和特权。在某种程度上，你现在拥有了其中一些东西。我想知道你是否能谈谈你自己的心路历程，以及你的心路历程可能如何改变了你，你是否看到自己
affected by the very same forces you describe in this book. Yeah, you know, I mean, it's so striking, you know, and it just comes back and bites you and you know, that as I've been lucky enough to get a good education and you know, become a professor and be on this show and have a voice, I find I am just as vulnerable to the power paradox as anybody. You know, I find that when I'm feeling powerful, suddenly my scientific acumen is in this sharp. I find when I'm feeling powerful, the way I speak to other people is a little diminished. Here's one of my favorite examples, and this is not a joke.
受到了你在本书中所描述的那些相同力量的影响。是的，你知道，我的意思是，这太醒目了，你知道的，它会回过头来反噬你，你知道的，随着我有幸接受了良好的教育，你知道的，成为了一名教授，并上了这个节目并拥有了发言权，我发现自己和任何人一样，同样容易受到权力悖论的影响。你知道，我发现当我感到有权力时，突然间我的科学敏锐度就没有那么敏锐了。我发现当我感到有权力时，我与其他人说话的方式有点下降了。这里有一个我最喜欢的例子，这不是一个笑话。
When I was writing the chapter about the car study that we just described about people driving fancy cars or feeling powerful, kind of driving in ethical ways, I went to pick up my daughter, who was rock climbing, a bunch of her friends, teenagers piled into the back of the car. I was feeling powerful and writing this chapter and feeling like a good dad. I was captivated by this sense and feeling like a good dad. I was captivated
当我正在写关于我们刚才描述的汽车研究的那一章时，关于开豪车或感到有权力的人，那种以不道德的方式开车，我去接我正在攀岩的女儿，她的一群朋友十几岁塞满了汽车后座。我当时感觉很有权力，在写这一章，觉得自己是个好爸爸。我被这种感觉迷住了，觉得自己是个好爸爸。我被这种感觉迷住了
by this sense of my own self-worth and I drove off and ran over my daughter's best friend's foot. Oh my god. I know and I could have cost a lot of serious damage, fortunately, I did not. But this is part of the lesson of the book, which is that power is part of every moment of our social lives. We've got to be aware of it. It can lead us to do foolish things and we should try to do the things that make it a force for good. Dagger Keltener, I want to thank you for talking with me today. It's been great to be with you, Shankar.
由于我自己的自我价值感，我开车出发时压到了我女儿最好朋友的脚。哦，天哪。我知道，这本可能会造成很多严重的损害，幸运的是，没有。但这是这本书的教训的一部分，那就是权力是我们社交生活的每一刻的一部分。我们必须意识到这一点。它会导致我们做一些愚蠢的事情，我们应该努力去做那些让它成为一股善力的事。达格·凯尔特纳（Dagger Keltener），我想感谢你今天与我交谈。很高兴能与你在一起，尚卡尔。
Dagger Keltener is a psychologist at the University of California. He's the author of the Power Paradox, How We Gain and Lose Influence. how we gain and lose influence. A few months after I spoke with Dr. Keltner, a news broke about a Hollywood executive who was parlaying his power to obtain sexual favors from producers and actresses. We turn next here to stunning new developments after the flood of accusations of sexual misconduct against Harvey Weinstein. Nearly 70 women have come forward with accusations. Over many years, Harvey Weinstein is set to have serially harassed multiple colleagues and co-workers.
达格·凯尔特纳是加州大学的心理学家。他是《权力悖论：我们如何获得与失去影响力》（The Power Paradox, How We Gain and Lose Influence）一书的作者。我们如何获得与失去影响力。在我与凯尔特纳博士交谈几个月后，一条新闻爆出，一名好莱坞高管利用自己的权力从制作人和女演员那里获取性贿赂。接下来，在针对哈维·韦恩斯坦（Harvey Weinstein）的大量性骚扰指控之后，我们转向这里令人震惊的新进展。将近70名女性站出来提出指控。多年来，据说哈维·韦恩斯坦一直在连环骚扰多名同事和工作伙伴。
In the months since that story broke, there have been a stream of other stories about powerful men accused of similar misconduct. Sexual harassment in the workplace is the topic today in our ongoing series of roles to see essentially this tsunami now of accusation. Promenin journalists like Charlie Rose, Bill O'Reilly and Matt Lauer have been among those who have been forced to step down from high-profile jobs in response to the allegations. As I read one story after the other, I couldn't help but think about Docker's research, that power hurts our ability to be empathetic.
在该故事曝光后的几个月里，涌现出了一系列关于被指控有类似不当行为的有权势男性的其他故事。职场性骚扰是我们今天在我们的系列节目中持续关注的话题，以了解基本上这股指控的巨大海啸。像查理·罗斯（Charlie Rose）、比尔·奥赖利（Bill O'Reilly）和马特·劳尔（Matt Lauer）这样的大牌记者，都是因这些指控而被迫辞去高调工作的人。当我阅读一个又一个故事时，我忍不住想起达格的研究，即权力损害了我们保持同理心的能力。
As stories came tumbling out in the news, I thought about the studies that show that power blinds people to the needs of others. It prompts them to become selfish, narcissistic, even abusive. DarkoRit turns out was thinking the same thing. He recently wrote for the Harvard Business Review, Powerful Men's studies show overestimate the sexual interest of others and erroneously believe that the women around them are more attracted to them than is actually the case. Powerful men also sexualize their work, looking for opportunities
随着各种故事在新闻中不断涌现，我想到了那些表明权力使人们对他人需求视而不见的研究。它促使他们变得自私、自恋，甚至具有虐待倾向。事实证明，达格·里特（DarkoRit）也有同感。他最近为《哈佛商业评论》撰文指出，研究表明，有权势的男性会高估其他人对性的兴趣，并错误地认为他们身边的女性比实际情况对他们更有吸引力。有权势的男性还会将他们的工作性化，寻找机会
for sexual trists and affairs, and along the way, lure inappropriately, stand too close, and touch for too long on a daily basis, thus crossing the lines of decorum and worse. Abuses of power are not just the result of a few bad apples. They are predictable and recurring. To stop them, we must focus not only on punishing perpetrators, but in being alert to the psychological danger of having and wielding power. In a few weeks, hidden brain is going to look more deeply at the issue of sexual harassment and misconduct. Women have been reporting horror stories for decades. What's prompted the sea change in the way those allegations are heard?
进行性幽会和外遇，在这个过程中，他们不恰当的调情，站得太近，每天触碰时间过长，从而跨越了礼仪的界限甚至更糟。对权力的滥用不仅仅是几个坏苹果的结果。它们是可预测且会反复发生的。为了阻止它们，我们不仅必须专注于惩罚犯罪者，还要对拥有和挥舞权力所带来的心理危险保持警惕。几周后，“隐藏大脑”（Hidden Brain）将更深入地探讨性骚扰和不当行为的问题。几十年来，女性一直在报告可怕的故事。是什么促成了人们听到这些指控方式的巨大转变？
Women, especially used to watch other women report and maybe lose their jobs or just not be heard at all or be disparaged. So that is the kind of social proof that used to inform women's decisions about reporting sexual harassment. That's coming up in a few weeks on Hidden Brain. This episode of Hidden Brain was produced by Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Pennman and Chris Benderiff. It was edited by Tara Boyle. We had original music from Louis Weeks and Nick DePray. Our staff includes Renee Clark, Parts Shah and Raina Cohen. NPR's Vice President for Programming is Anya Grunman.
女性，尤其是过去常常看着其他女性举报，然后可能失去工作，或者根本不被倾听，或者被诋毁。这就是过去用来影响女性关于举报性骚扰决策的那种社会证明。这将在几周后的“隐藏大脑”节目中播出。本期“隐藏大脑”由珍妮·施密特（Jenny Schmidt）、玛吉·佩恩曼（Maggie Pennman）和克里斯·本德里夫（Chris Benderiff）制作。由塔拉·博伊尔（Tara Boyle）编辑。我们有来自路易斯·威克斯（Louis Weeks）和尼克·德普雷（Nick DePray）的原创音乐。我们的员工包括雷妮·克拉克（Renee Clark）、帕茨·沙阿（Parts Shah）和雷娜·科恩（Raina Cohen）。NPR的节目副总裁是安妮娅·格伦曼（Anya Grunman）。
For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook, Twitter and Instagram and listen from my stories on Morning Edition each week on your local public radio station. Hidden Brain is also a podcast, so be sure to subscribe to us on iTunes, NPR1 or wherever you get your podcasts. Please also tell your friends about Hidden Brain, we're always looking for new people to find our show. I'm Shankar Vidantam, see you next week. See you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
想要了解更多“隐藏大脑”的内容，您可以在Facebook、Twitter和Instagram上关注我们，并每周在您当地的公共广播电台的“早间版”（Morning Edition）收听我的故事。“隐藏大脑”也是一个播客，所以请务必在iTunes、NPR1或您获取播客的任何地方订阅我们。也请向您的朋友们推荐“隐藏大脑”，我们一直在寻找新的人来发现我们的节目。我是尚卡尔·维丹塔姆（Shankar Vidantam），下周见。下周见。本期节目目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。